[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory in
today's video we're going to be
discussing the moral leanings of albus
percival wolfrick brian dumbledore
beloved hogwarts professor and eventual
headmaster loyal member of the order of
the phoenix and potentially dark wizard
now don't get me wrong dumbledore was a
majorly positive influence on our dear
boy harry providing him with guidance in
the wizarding world and taking a special
interest in the boy who lived upon its
arrival at hogwarts i also want to make
my stance on dumbledore abundantly clear
he's one of my favorite characters so
this is not a shot at him this is just a
fun theory to explore but what if
dumbledore's influence his interest in
harry came from a selfish dark place
rather than a selfless compassionate one
could it be that albus dumbledore only
mentored harry only ever did things that
appeared good in general to satisfy his
own need to be clever to be powerful and
ultimately to achieve glory let's take a
look at the facts i've got three for you
today
number one if dumbledore truly cared for
harry why did he abuse him so often
i don't mean abuse in the physical sense
of course although there were quite a
few times where he sent harry off to do
some very questionable very dangerous
things but in terms of emotional abuse
dumbledore left harry alone to suffer
almost too many times to count the first
time was when harry was just a baby for
some odd reason not agreed upon by
anyone else i might add namely minerva
mcgonagall and hagrid dumbledore chose
to place a newly orphaned infant harry
in the care of the dursleys he did this
knowing of the volatile and strained
relationship between lily potter harry's
mother and her sister petunia and with
witches like arabella fig the dursley's
neighbor who would frequently care for
harry when the dursleys would go out to
do something fun without harry of course
dumbledore was certainly aware of how
harry was being treated over at number
four private drive i mean harry's letter
of acceptance to hogwarts was literally
made out to mr h potter the cupboard
under the stairs number four private
drive so dumbledore clearly knew of the
abuse harry was experiencing and yet he
remained in the care of the dursleys for
an entire decade and no one seemed to be
too concerned when he continued to
return to private drive each and every
summer either but yes yes i know what
you're thinking didn't harry have to
live there in order to remain safe
dumbledore even explains this to harry
himself while you can still call home
the place where your mother's blood
dwells there you cannot be touched or
harmed by voldemort he shed her blood
but it lives on in you and her sister
her blood became your refuge you need
return there only once a year but as
long as you can still call it home there
he cannot hurt you so according to
dumbledore at least he had to be there
we know the power of love is real in
harry potter but living with the
dursleys is that bit actually true or is
this just another manipulation tactic
used by dumbledore as part of his scheme
dumbledore also continued to be somewhat
indifferent and mistrusting of harry as
the years progressed despite claiming to
care for him he didn't seem to believe
harry when he said he didn't put his own
name into the goblet of fire for
instance and then after the triwizard
tournament ended an incredibly traumatic
event for harry instead of explaining to
harry his theory behind his link to
voldemort or merely even comforting
harry what did he do instead he ignored
him later he claimed he only did this to
keep harry safe but he actually didn't
want harry to know that he would
inevitably have to die more on this in a
second dumbledore then continued to
withhold important information from him
right up until his death leaving a
teenage harry to decipher complex
riddles and clues hunt down dangerous
magical items and ultimately come up
against one of the most powerful dark
wizards of all time voldemort it's also
worth pointing out that dumbledore has
also earned a lot of disapproval from
fans over the years who believed he
mentored harry for only one despicable
reason to be raised like a pig for
slaughter we have protected him because
it has been essential to teach him to
raise him to let him try his strength
said dumbledore his eyes still tight
shut meanwhile the connection between
them grows ever stronger a parasitic
growth sometimes they have thought he
suspects it himself if i know him he
will have arranged matters so that when
he does set out to meet his death it
will truly mean the end of voldemort
dumbledore opened his eyes snape looked
horrified you have kept him alive so
that he could die at the right moment
don't be shocked severus how many men
and women have you watched to die
dumbledore knew and quite frankly didn't
sound too distraught about the fact that
harry would have to give his life in
order to defeat voldemort he provided
him with just enough guidance to have
him become a compassionate powerful
young wizard who would be willing to
sacrifice himself for the greater good
number two the wizards who dumbledore
chose to be loyal to was also
questionable to say the least the most
obvious example is of course
dumbledore's affiliation with the
infamous wizard gelet grindelwald who
was considered to be one of the most
dangerous wizards of all time
grindelwald and dumbledore struck up an
intense relationship as young men over
their shared interest in power in the
pursuit of the three deathly hallows
while dumbledore eventually realized how
far into dark magic and hate grindelwald
was willing to take his ideologies it
took decades before he was willing to
challenge him in a duel
he eventually did in 1945 at the height
of grindelwald's power but why did it
take so long you might ask likely a
couple of reasons
since the release of the books jk
rowling has revealed that dumbledore was
in fact in love with grindelwald then
one of their final confrontations before
going their separate ways as young men
led to the death of dumbledore's sister
ariana so he was in love with the
psychopath and not even the death of a
family member was enough to make him go
after him
quite an unwavering loyalty to a very
wicked wizard not the best look for
dumbledore on a much lesser scale in
terms of loyalties to dark wizards
dumbledore seemed to have interesting
taste when it came to who he employed at
hogwarts obviously he also gave
well-intentioned and talented magical
folks career opportunities the likes of
handgrid and simple trelloni falling
into the well-intentioned category and
professors like rumors lupin falling
into the talented and good category but
he also chose wizards like queerness
quirrell and horace slughorn to take up
postings at hogwarts it's hard to
believe that the wizard with
dumbledore's experience and power
wouldn't have been able to tell that
something was really quite off about
quirrell i mean the man had voldemort's
soul living on the back of his head
dumbledore also went quite out of his
way to offer slughorn a job now i know
he wanted slughorn's help in determining
exactly how voldemort split his soul but
did he really have to give him a paying
job in order to get that information out
of him after all slughorn was a man of
questionable morality putting together a
club for his most talented students
showing a shallow enthusiasm for knowing
students would go on to be great despite
seeing darkness in some of them
including you guessed it a young tom
riddle
on the flip side of that coin dumbledore
didn't always show the most loyalty
towards otherwise good wizards for
example being in the order of the
phoenix and watching him come up in
hogwarts with james potter i would have
expected dumbledore to ask more
questions when it came to sirius black
and the death of james and lily not only
did he do nothing to uncover the truth
of what happened before sirius was
imprisoned in azkaban dumbledore even
went as far as to allow dementors to
roam school grounds in an effort to
protect students after sirius escaped
from prison number three the third and
final piece of evidence that i've got
for you guys today is i would say his
most unforgivable the mistreatment of
his family we've already covered the
fact that he was part of the jewel that
led to the death of his younger sister
ariana whether he was at fault for the
spell that killed her or not remains
beside the point if he hadn't been so
careless around his family you could
argue that the tragedy could have been
avoided altogether but even before that
as a young man filled with pride he
resented that he must care for his
damaged sister after she accidentally
killed their mother in an outburst of
uncontrollable magic in order to come
take care of ariana alba's had to
cancel a trip around the world with his
friend bill fires doge oh the horrors
no not really and from my perspective he
seems much more distraught of the loss
of his freedom than the loss of his
mother i resented it harry dumbledore
stated it baldly coldly he was looking
now over the top of harry's head into
the distance
i was gifted i was brilliant i wanted to
escape i wanted to shine i wanted glory
do not misunderstand me he said and pain
crossed the face so that he looked
ancient again i loved them i loved my
parents i loved my brother my sister but
i was selfish harry more selfish than
you who are a remarkably selfless person
could possibly imagine so that when my
mother died and i was left the
responsibility of a damaged sister and a
wayward brother i returned to my village
in anger and bitterness
trapped and wasted i thought so there
you have it three things that point to
albus dumbledore potentially being more
evil than any of us had previously
expected did i miss any examples of
dumbledore acting truly evil or do you
think this is a completely crazy theory
after all even harry managed to find the
good in dumbledore forgiving him when
they meet in limbo at king's cross in
the deathly hallows regardless let me
know your thoughts on this one in the
comments below and don't forget to like
the video and subscribe to the channel
until next time dumbledore's army still
recruiting
you